what can i do oh your services will not
be necessary
because you need to go home and change
for your date what
i called handsome luke i explained the
weekend was entirely my fault partially
and he wants to go out with you tonight
thanks peralta you're welcome
just promise me you won't use the
condoms in the secret pocket of your
purse okay they're expired how do you
know it's in my purse
i need a concealer for zit plus
you know we spent so much time together
here i know everything about everyone
hitchcock went bald at 15. scully used
to date hitchcock's wife
charles has a bike with a little basket
on the front how else would you carry
baguettes
and rosa has a shower in her apartment i
think i got nothing on her
good well i guess we did just spend 48
hours locked in here together
holy crap what locked in here together
so we will be filing a wrongful rest
suit against the nypd
and when i win i'm gonna buy club twerk
put a statue of jake peralta right in
the middle of dance floor
first off that's a terrible threat i
would love to have a statue of myself in
the middle of a dance club
second do me a favor take a look at this
picture and tell me what you see
you and regis philbin awesome right
surprisingly down to earth guy and
definitely not the picture i meant to
show you
but take a look at this that's right
it's you and your old cellmate marcus
cole
and here he is again outside the jewelry
store
the two you planned this together in
prison you taught him your ammo
he pulled off the robbery you got
yourself an alibi and you split the loot
oh man i can't believe he caught us of
course he did peralta is the best
oh thanks rege that's enough yeah i got
to work on my regis anyway see you in
jail whitman
i rewatched the interrogation and get
this
sophia wasn't lying about anything she
doesn't know who killed nate dexter but
she does know something way better
come with me
jay people normally move after they say
that
oh yeah i fell asleep for a second sorry
come with me
okay ah you all ready for this you know
what i'm saying
terry jeffords allow me to introduce to
you
our murder victim the not dead
nate dexter what the hell is going on
right sophia wasn't lying i was just not
asking the right
questions she hadn't seen her husband in
eight years but she was positive there's
no way that he killed dexter
that's when it occurred to me no one
killed him
hey nate just talking about how you're
alive yeah i'm alive
but whose melted torso did we find
sofia's husband yes sophia and dexter
were having an affair
husband found out nate killed him now
i'm telling my friend about how you
killed that guy
it was for love cool motive still murder
also you remember that severed finger
check this out hey nate show us your
hands please
oh right cut it off himself
how screwed up is that anyway i asked
all my cis if they had dealings with a
nine-fingered man
unsolvable case solved
what's going on oh nothing just had a
real eye-opening conversation with your
dad i wanted his approval but he says
i'll never be good enough for you what
the hell
i know right tell him he's wrong no i'm
upset with you
that's right go get him tiger i'm also
upset with you what is this 1950
i can't date someone unless i have my
father's approval oh obviously you can
you guys act like this is your decision
to make
like the woman doesn't even exist in
this equation well this woman
wait amy shut up excuse me i mean i'm so
sorry you were making a totally valid
point about gender equality but i just
thought of something really important so
i'm gonna hang up on you okay love you
bye
it wasn't russo or his sons it was a
daughter
hello everyone guess who just solved a
20 year old unsolvable case
wait what you guys figured out who
pulled the first sussex bank job yeah
we realized we never checked the
daughter's alibi she wasn't at the
softball trip
she had access to the plants and then
she just confessed
that's right we arrested a woman today
because we are feminists
what up jake why are these dicks out of
their cage i stayed up all night working
on your case and hans john and nakatomi
made for great company
i gave them all die hard names i don't
understand why you wasted another night
on a case no one's ever gonna solve
sarge i am way too sleep deprived to
deal with your negativity right now
let me show you what i did i started off
by making a map of all of the burglaries
that have gone down in brooklyn since
1996 to see if there was a pattern
that led me to this
there is so much crime in new york no
one should live here
anyways i tripped out on that for a
couple hours but i got cheered up
after i took a picture of the kitties
messing around in my little hoodie i'll
show it to you later
so basically you wasted a whole night no
no no my friend no no cause then i dove
back into your file
and found this cool
the low point my entire life sarge this
photo was taken in 1996.
you told me your guy broke his spine two
years before that so 94
check out his sneakers 95
jordans they came out a year after the
accident look at the souls
they're all muddy which means that son
of a [ __ ]
can walk bingo
hey there remember me
[Music]
so this is weird oh no you don't circus
i knew it you could walk the whole time
i was right about the cater conference
too huh now where's the cat
been 20 years sarge cat's probably dead
i'm still bringing him in
i told you not to lie what were you
thinking
i thought it would work and i wanted to
be the one that got him is this about
your ego
are you that desperate for everyone to
know how great you are it's not about
everyone
okay it's just i wanted you to know
oh my god
i got it he's not answering any
questions that's okay i have no
questions that's right
i'm about to monologue son better make
it quick you only got eight minutes
all right then let me paint you a
picture i'm phillip a successful
periodontist that's become addicted to
diazepam a sedative i take because i'm
junkie scum
also for real addiction is a disease
that would be super empathetic if you
hadn't murdered a man what is the point
of this i'll get there so
one day i'm working late when my boss
robert surprises me he found out i was
stealing meds again jackie's gum also
again not your fault there's a major
genetic component to addiction he says
he's gonna file a police report
i could lose my license we fight and
something in me just snaps so i grab the
first thing i can find
and i hit him with it you still have no
murder weapon i do now
here's a pic i found on yelp of the
surgical suite six months ago and here's
a shot that our crime scene photographer
took up the same room two weeks after
the murder notice any differences we're
not answering that that's all right i
can just tell you myself the yelp shot
has six of these heavy-looking glass
awards from the brooklyn periodontics
society in the background whereas this
shot only has
five what happened to number six you
murdered robert with him
you lost all control and you bludgeoned
him to death there must have been blood
everywhere but you got lucky
you were in the surgical suite it can be
sterilized you never would have gotten
away with it in your carpeted office
that's not what happened don't say
anything more funny and your office
manager would have heard all of the
screaming but she was at her grandson's
play
lucky again you're wrong you put
robert's body into a wheelchair and
shoved it in the elevator it's a miracle
there wasn't blood everywhere that's not
true
now you're in the garage with a corpse
you panicked and left your phone in your
office
and you don't have your car keys but
roberts are in his pocket so you put him
in his car
and you take off no you can't believe
what you've done no you're flustered you
have no gps so you just start driving no
fill up next thing you know you're in
the pine barrens and it hits you your
uncle's cabin he has a place there
you're the luckiest son of a woman
yes it was you got lucky at every turn
no i knew exactly where i was driving i
left my phone in the office on purpose i
was in a surgical suite by design and i
didn't use some glass award that any
idiot would clearly see was missing
i made a rod out of a special dental
polymer killed him with it and melted it
back down
it's already in a patient's mouth son
oh damn oh damn oh
damn and that is 3-0 dams
oh damn
oh fresh air
wow i don't say that a lot there's one
thing i still don't
understand did you know you had the
wrong murder weapon oh
excellent question sir yes i spotted the
missing dental award when i first took
the case i asked around weeks ago it
turns out a cleaning lady knocked it
over and shattered it then why did you
run in there like that because in
talking to you i realized what philip's
worst fear actually was
that we would think he was just some
dummy that got lucky right
he had planned the perfect crime and it
killed him when you said he was sloppy
and impulsive he needed us to know how
smart he was
hi like someone else i know
yep kevin
i'm proud of you peralta thank you sir
now let's go get some sleep yeah hey
guys
my goodness we're almost late for work
oh well in that case
good morning sir good morning
god i love this job
you